hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
taten welt heute mache ich leckere putin
teilchen und zwar ist es ein türkisches
rezept welches ich jetzt für euch
vorbereitet habe das ist ein hefeteig
aber da hat auch backpulver mitteln und
dazu einfach den vorteil dass man den
hefeteig eben zubereitet und die dann
aber gleich weiterverarbeiten kann und
dann eben nur einmal gehen lassen muss
und dann das direkt backen kann das
heißt diese pudding dahlien sind eben
richtig schnell gemacht und deswegen
zeig ich euch jetzt auch ganz schnell
mal die zutaten
ich habe hier für 500 gramm mehl da habe
ich hier aber htc desire und das eigelb
kommen dann später um auf die teilchen
drauf zu bestreichen
ich habe hier 100 milliliter öl und zwar
ist es in sonnenblumenöl ein teelöffel
salz eine packung backpulver ein würfel
frischhefe ich habe es hier ein bisschen
wasser das sind so etwa 2 3 esslöffel
hier habe ich 80 gramm zucker und 250
milliliter zimmer warme milch
das waren jetzt die zutaten für den teig
und jetzt kommen hier die zutaten für
die füllung und zwar habe ich meinen
vanilleschoten extrakt soll nämlich
einen vanillepudding werden
da habe ich hier 3 150 milliliter milch
hier habe ich 60 gramm zucker und 40 kw
45 g speisestärke und zum bestreichen
und zur dekoration brauche ich noch
dieses eine
ich habe einen teelöffel puderzucker das
möchte ich dann gleich zum eigelb mit
rein hier noch so ein paar
mandelblättchen und puderzucker zum
bestreuen
sie ist noch ziemlich viel aus aber es
ist gar nicht so viel sind eigentlich
alles grundzutaten ich muss auch dafür
nicht extra einkaufen gehen ich hatte
alles geheim
ich bereite jetzt zuerst mal den pudding
zu den während der dann abkühlen kann
kann ich den teig machen
man kann praktisch alles vorbereiten und
ich denke so innerhalb von 40 minuten
einer stunde haben wir komplett das
ganze gericht oder die ganzen teilchen
besser gesagt zubereitet so für den
manila pudding nämlich jetzt die stärke
und geht da ein bisschen milch reihen
wobei ich mach das jetzt hier weil ich
verschüttete sind auf jeden fall
ich mache das jetzt direkt im topf oder
ist noch kalt weil ich glaube ich da
rein kippte
verlängere ich also ich gebe es einfach
ein bisschen milch hier in den topf
gucken und ich hab richtig geschafft
sich jetzt komplett verlagert
dann kommt da die stärke mit rein und
die rührige kurz klümpchen frei und zum
schneebesen
und wenn es dann soweit habt könnt ihr
die restliche nämlich mit rein geben
dann auch den zucker und das vanille
extrakt ihr könnt natürlich auch fertige
vanille packung nehmen so ein vanille
pudding und einfach weniger - nehmen
aber ich finde es ist eine stärke drin
und zucker und mir eigentlich nur
stärker vanille und farbstoffen sehen
wir jetzt unser pudding aufweise nicht
gelb so dass früher ich jetzt kurz und
lass es jetzt aufkochen
den pudding dass ich jetzt hier einfach
etwas abkühlen und fühle mich jetzt um
den teig und zwar nehme ich jetzt hier
für meinen wasser und predator jetzt die
hefe hinein
und das verriet einmal ganz kurz und
löst einfach die hefe im wasser auf das
wasser ist übrigens so ungefähr hand
warm also nicht wärmer hat ungefähr 30
grad
und da gebe ich jetzt noch ein bisschen
vom zucker mit treiben einfach so als
nahrung für die hilfe jetzt gebe ich
diese hefe wasser mischung einfach in
rührschüssel ich mache jetzt den teig
mit einer küchenmaschine aber den kann
man auch super per hand verkneten
man muss dann einfach nur darauf achten
dass man ihn lange genug knetet also so
zwischen fünf und zehn minuten wäre
optimal gebe ich den restlichen zucker
mit rein dann das mehl aber noch nicht
komplett alles ich mich erstmal so
bisschen was verrühren dann die milch
und das eiweiß und das lasse ich jetzt
kurz verrühren
jetzt versuche ich hier kurz das
backpulver mit dem restlichen mehr
einfach damit sich so ein bisschen
auflösen kann
und eben nicht so klümpchen bildet
jetzt gebe ich einfach nach und nach das
mehl dazu dann auf das öl
jetzt lassen wir das so etwa fünf bis
zehn minuten lang verkneten
mein teig wurde jetzt verknetet und es
ist sonntag der klebt auch nicht sehr
falsch aber euch zu klebrig ist könnte
so ein bisschen mehr noch dazu geben ich
habe auch ungefähr noch 20 bis 30 gramm
dazu gegeben
kommt einfach immer darauf an wie groß
eben das eiweiß ist da ganz einfach sein
dass ein bisschen mehr drauf und es geht
mir denn auf einer arbeitsfläche und
pakete jetzt natürlich ein bisschen aber
das ist nicht schlimm und daraus werde
ich jetzt ungefähr 20 bis 25 teilchen
machen ein bisschen mehl aber nicht zu
viel
gerade dass da jetzt nicht so sehr klebt
man könnte jetzt auch auf einer silikon
mathearbeiten wollte jetzt eigentlich
auch machen aber ich schneide den teig
gleich ein und da ist nicht so gut wie
immer auf der matte schneidet und jetzt
vorm ich mir da einfach so eine lange
rolle
mit dem durchmesser my name is ned
morath am hochhaus am start und nehme
mir da einfach so ein kleines stück ab
mit einer tankkarte das kann man jetzt
natürlich auch auf messen aber heute
nehmen muss man nicht ganz so genau
und die haben jetzt so etwa schätzen 40
gramm
also ich kann das nicht ich muss das
einfach nur mal abrufen ich mache jetzt
45 gramm benson 48 geht auch
jetzt freue ich mich einfach so kleine
bällchen daraus und legst du mir da oben
hin und bereit ist eben kurz vor
perfektes timing ich bin nämlich gerade
fertig geworden
ich habe es jetzt nicht abgezählt aber
ich schätze es sind ungefähr 20 und
jetzt nehme ich mir ein bällchen welches
sich zuerst geformt hatte und der teig
lässt sich auch echt super verarbeiten
so schön weich und auch nicht so klebrig
ich brauche es nur noch ganz wenig mehl
ich mein gut ich habe dann immer viel
rhythmus nach film und rollt es jetzt
mit einem ausbaustopp aus eine
spülmaschine will man mit ins wieder so
ein bisschen ovals gern auch mal in die
breite aber nicht so arg in breite und
jetzt kommt davon der pudding masse mit
drauf
und zwar stecke ich mir da einfach der
schutz richtig schön stichfest stelle
ich mir da so ein bisschen was ab mit
einem esslöffel und gibt es da rein und
ich hab hier noch ein paar mandarinen
abtropfen lassen
einfach einen sieg und gibt jetzt auch
mit rein ich dachte feld summe also wenn
wir mit der ktm abgestimmt waren hinter
den kulissen dass das mit pudding
vielleicht so langweilig wird und
deswegen kommt einfach mit mandarine
betreiben alternativ könnte man zum
beispiel auch kirschen nehmen oder auch
vielleicht äpfel oder so wird auch ganz
super passen
und jetzt nehme ich mir ein messer und
schneidet hier oben die andere hälfte so
ein bisschen ein
denn das wird jetzt gleich ein richtig
schönes richtig schöne optik gehalten
und jetzt müsst ihr einfach das ganze
umschlagen und zwar den teil mit dem
pudding schlag ich ein und drückst zu
damit einfach der pudding jetzt nicht
raus läuft und dann rolle ich das ganze
weiter so richtig schnee fest
und dann setzte ich hier auf meinen
backblech und phorms aber noch ein
bisschen wieso einhalten und praktisch
so kleine halbmondförmige hörnchen
und so mache ich das jetzt einfach
weiter und jetzt alternativ zu den
pudding könnte natürlich auch eine
leckere quark stellung nehmen mag ich
sowieso eigentlich so mein favorit
reiseplaner stückchen oder man könnte
eine ausbildung machen da könnte den
ausbildung von meinem justus zum
beispiel nehmen oder irgendwas anderes
man könnte auch eine füllung aus kirchen
machen sondern richtig fruchtige
füllungen oder vielleicht fällt euch da
noch was ein und ihr könnt ihr einfach
schreiben was ihr noch für eine
verlosung als alternative hätte
schokopudding schoko pudding gut machen
kann und da vielleicht dann so
schattenmorellen das passt richtig gut
wenn ihr schokopudding machen wollte
könnte er einfach so ungefähr 50 bis 100
km kuvertüre in der milch auflösen und
dann habt dann schokopudding
zu sehen jetzt meine hand hinaus ich
habe jetzt 12 auf einem blech denen die
gehen ja gleich noch auf und man sieht
auch deutlich während ich die letzten
noch fertig machen gehen die ersten auch
schon richtig gut auf ich denke die
jetzt mit ein bisschen frischhaltefolie
ab und lasst sie jetzt einfach so eine
halbe stunde etwa gehen und danach
können wir sie dann direkt packen
aber ich zeige euch auf jeden fall
vorher wie sie dann eben aussehen wenn
es aufgegangen sind
meine zweite posten ist jetzt auch
soweit fertig und solange ich dir
gemacht habe dürften hier die anderen
aufgehen
und das heißt ich kann jetzt hier
abdecken und die gehen lassen und kann
jetzt die hier zum backen vorbereiten
man sieht jetzt auch ganz deutlich den
unterschied kann ich jetzt auch mal
zeigen also die sind echt fast doppelt
so groß deswegen müsse das wirklich mit
viel abstand auch ein blech setzen und
ist nehme ich hier meinen main ab da ein
esslöffel wasser mit rein und verrät so
ein bisschen am besten in dem größeren
gefäß und da gebe ich jetzt noch den
puderzucker mir dazu oder das anders
strom und da kann nämlich dazu an der
oberfläche so ein bisschen karamell 4
und jetzt nehme ich einfach einen celik
opel und kam die teilchen mit pinseln
ist auch immer sehr wichtig die erste
pinseln bin sie aufgegangen sind
denn sonst kann es passieren dass eben
durch das eigelb weil es hatte so eine
bindung dass es dann einfach auf platz
und es wäre dann ziemlich hässlich es
wird das dann auch nicht mehr gut
aufgehen
jetzt kann ich meine mantel blätter
nehmen und die einfach nur so ein
bisschen drüber streuen sie natürlich
schön aus und schmeckt auch sehr lecker
weil die dann im ofen so richtig knackig
werden und ich mach das ziel kurz und
dann kommen sie in den vorgeheizten
backofen bei ungefähr 190 grad für etwa
20 minuten
wenn sie auf jeden fall auf der
oberfläche goldbraun sind können das
herausnehmen und dann zeige ich euch
gleich das endergebnis
so sind jetzt meine leckeren hähnchen
aus und hier in der wohnung duftet auch
richtig nach selbst gebackenen und ich
habe jetzt ganz kurz abkühlen das und
damit ist anfassen kann denn sonst wären
es zu heiß und ich finde guck mal jetzt
doch noch richtig schöne farbe und vor
allem die mandelblättchen da oben sind
jetzt auch richtig groß und knackig
richtig lecker eben ich spreche das
jetzt einfach mal auf und dann sieht man
auch schon wie locker das ganze ist und
ich denke genauso gut wie es riecht
schmeckt wahrscheinlich auch
richtig lecker auch einfach mal so zum
frühstück oder mittags zum täter oder
zum kaffee und ich habe übrigens auch
welche mit nutella gefüllt sind aber
noch im backofen
sonst hätte ich ihr euch jetzt auch
gezeigt und ich denke man kann sie auch
ganz gut mit einem salzigen hefeteig
machen also dass man einfach statt dem
ganzen zucker nur ein teelöffel zucker
mit rein gibt und dann kann man sie zum
beispiel viel mit käse mit schinken mit
allem möglichen kannst du dann schon
eine rolle ich denke da mache ich
vielleicht mal ein video drüber
vielleicht habt ihr noch anregungen mit
waffen was eben noch füllen könnte und
wir lassen sie uns jetzt hier schmecken
und ihr dürft das rezept nachlesen auf
sales blog.de und wir sehen uns dann
beim nächsten mal wieder bis bald
tschüss